I think 38 to 65 is the obvious really
interesting age group that should really
be [__] paying attention to
technology and the opportunities for
them all the 20 year olds are jumping
into this game and meanwhile all the 40
year olds and 50 year olds are more
likely to win it because they have
context I look at a 22 year old dude
who's like I'm starting a startup
company and then a 49 year old woman
walks in and says I've been an
accountant for 23 years I want to build
this startup she always interests me
more because usually the next thing out
of her mouth is yeah I've been an
accountant for 31 years
I noticed that I couldn't find the
product that helped me do this she's
scratching her itch from experience it
is that 40 50 38 53 that does get me
going because it's a lot of time it's a
little wild especially when you start
thinking about seven and being 11. it's
like 40 000 years ago you're gonna live
an entire another life I don't
understand why people would settle I
just don't